hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna have a short stream because I
forgot that I told someone I would meet
them and check out their computer and
figure out why one of the websites I
built wasn't working on their computer
at noon so it's 11 a.m. here right now
so that means the stream has to be a
little less than an hour their office is
just right around the corner for mine so
it shouldn't be if I can finish like
three minutes before noon
that'll be give me enough time so
apologies for that I know we usually go
longer than an hour I just I literally I
remember five minutes ago so it just
totally slipped my mind and I never put
in my calendar so anyway we're just
going to get started right away I okay
yeah I know there's probably not the
normal amount of viewers in here yet I
like to wait a minute but since we have
a tight schedule I'm just going to go on
probably just going to do one Pomodoro
session and then questions if there's
not really that many questions then
maybe we'll do a little bit more but
definitely we'll get two full sessions
in so let me start up the clock today we
are gonna upgrade my package.json so
today we're gonna upgrade to the stable
version of Apollo graph QL 2.1 so let's
go to where we have that right now so
it's the package name is react Apollo so
right now we're at two point one point
Oh beta zero and we had thanks to
Harshit we had some workarounds
happening that enabled this to work but
at first when we tried to use this there
were some issues so now that this is no
longer your beta we should be fine to
use it so I'm
I think I should be able to just do this
change that and then run yarn if I can't
just do this somebody let me know so I
mean what we're gonna do we're not just
gonna install this and say hey we're
done today we're gonna install it and
then we're gonna go in and update
everything that's still using the the
old way like using a higher-order
component we're gonna update that and
try to use the new way whenever we can
which if you're not familiar with a new
way we had used it on some components
before but now we use it and I'm gonna
link to you a blog post that explains
more about what is new and why we might
want to use this so I'm gonna link that
right now it's in the live chat if the
link in the live chat does not work try
copying and pasting it sometimes if you
if you click right on it it's it doesn't
work all right so let's try this and
then we'll check the following correct
for your dependency
we got some morning's about peer
dependencies but I think I don't think
that's a big deal
follow client okay let's see you know
what let me double check the Apollo I
thought I had it up on my screen the
github repo I guess I must have closed
that said so I'm gonna check this really
quickly just to see what the with the
versions are
I guess we could try to do update Apollo
maybe we could update the other stuff I
mean it looks it looks okay
I think it looks alright let if anybody
notices anything weird with this or
notices of the look something wrong let
me know but I mean we've already had if
we were installing it fresh we would
want to install some other stuff too
well we already have all that other
stuff so I think we'll be fine
I mean if we really wanted to we could
try to update all the other things yeah
let's try to do that what is that you're
in command oh no I didn't have the right
camera on sorry about that so sorry I
can't believe I did that
as in such a hurry ok so basically we
have react Apollo all I did was type in
yarn after changing the version number
so that's what I did but I think I just
want to upgrade the other a packages
that have to do with this so like in
particular these Apollo packages graph
QL you know these ones so I just can't
remember is it yarn upgrade or yarn
update if I want to update packages no
need of upgrade Harshit says it's good
no need to upgrade those other packages
oh yeah harsh it says they're separate I
know they're separate but I'm just
wondering since the last time we added
those are there updates and should we
just go ahead and update them right now
okay aditya says you're an upgrade
interactive latest okay and that'll let
us go through right and see saying what
we want to upgrade right now all right
let's do that then all right so let's
see what we have all right this is cool
I never did it this way this is really
cool
choose which packages cool
I guess what
we should upgrade these material icons
since we are now are at the latest
version of material UI I suppose like we
would want the version to match so all
right a lot of these look like minor
stuff obviously because they're green Oh
more choices here yes yeah I don't want
to mess with any with some of these that
are red right now until we read up on
them yeah so what's now I have you
selected I'm good to go with Enter is
that it
okay okay double-checking the live chat
here cuz I know if I'm about to do
something really crazy you all let me
know so there we go so let's try this I
really ought to have a schedule to just
update packages so I don't end up having
packages really on a date maybe I should
just set a day like every week we're
just gonna update packages does that
sound like a good plan what do people
normally do is there for those of you
who are developers you're working or you
have worked with other developers before
do you is there usually some schedule or
what with some way to keep these things
up-to-date what's the normal thing
normal way to do it this is one of the
downfalls of me you know working by
myself most of the time when it comes to
things like this I don't really know
what the standard is
Harshit says you need greenkeeper bought
package maintainer x' use greenkeeper
bought or some sort of not in github
some sort of bought and github okay
alright cool have to look into that I
mean realistically we have a lot of
stuff going on and I know we have
outdated packages running on things and
it's the more we make the harder it's
gonna be to manually keep up with that
alright so let me you know what on my
other screen I'm going to type in green
keeper bought and that way I'll remember
it after the stream because I know I'm
have to go right to a meeting after this
so I'm likely to forget unless I already
have it on my screen okay so there it's
it's on my other screen and oh cool
harsh it says the bot makes a pull
request every time a package changes
that's that's amazing that's really cool
I'll all right if you learn nothing else
from today's stream remember greenkeeper
bought will automatically make a pull
request every time a package updates in
one of your projects that's amazing
that's really cool
all right well looks like we have
everything updated first thing I'd like
to do is just make sure that things are
still working and then we can actually
go in if we need to correct a problem we
will correct it if there are no problems
we'll go in and upgrade to some of the
newer stuff that we can do now and
hopefully that will help help the
project to be more like uniform right
now we're using two different ways or I
should say we're using the new way in
some places and then the other place
it's just broken because I I'm pretty
sure it doesn't work all right so we're
not using it here on this page so that
wouldn't really be useful to go to let's
go to a page where we are using this all
right nice check out these error
messages all have to do with material UI
and I think so basically we haven't
changed yet so I believe neeki open an
issue for this but when we upgraded to
the latest version of material I beta
we're now getting a warning because of
this underline I think on the inputs so
I haven't fixed that yet so that's why
we have all that read there and I can
run end grukk as well and they all check
it out for yourselves
there we are okay so it looks good also
I have all the links now on the About
section they all should work some of
them are external links but all these
links should not work and I have started
in on academics so I'm going through
it's taking a while because I'm going
through in some of these places have
like submenus you can't see them here
they're on the the live site right now
so I need a way to bring in some of
those sub menus I'm still thinking about
how to do that but anyway so it's not
just these pages like for instance I'd
go into this consumer information page
and then there are links here that I'd
go through and make sure each one of
these links also works so it's taking me
quite a while so that's what if you're
under incarcerating I'm spending doing
that with links or going through a huge
Excel spreadsheet that has every piece
of data that we've gotten out of the
database and I'm color coding ones that
like I need to input or I need to ask my
boss about this is whether or not we're
input and I'm trying to get rid of
things that we're definitely not
bringing over or we already have brought
over because I want to make sure I don't
miss anything
so it's a little tedious but it's really
the only way I can be sure that I
haven't missed anything
yeah because at the end of it I should
have nothing left in that spreadsheet
everything should be deleted and if I
have anything left I know I'm not done
all right so this looks good this works
so I'm really trying to think if there
would be I guess we could try out a
profile a faculty profile just to be
sure I don't think we're doing anything
differently yeah that works
okay now let's go in and see what we're
doing that's so different let me let me
commit this first we're gonna get add if
you're not familiar with yet this is you
do it you'll be doing this routine over
and over over again when you start using
it and it just said hey hey how's it
going
so you do a get add to stage your files
that you want to commit
now the follows are staged and then you
do in our project we do yarn CM but
normally you would do this you do get
commit and then do an M and then put
your commit message in then type answer
we're going to do yarn cm all that does
is it's exactly the same thing
it just asks you a few questions to help
you make a better commit message so all
right well what were using when we
update stuff I can't remember what it
was was it Shh
was it chore or build it was build okay
oh that's cool yeah it says right there
dependencies okay
all right so we're gonna go to build I'm
just double-checking these I never read
these ones down here very cool all right
sure so now we're gonna write a short
description and this is what you would
normally put in the parentheses after
the EM flag if you were just committing
using the normal git commit command and
we're just going to say update Apollo
packages the latest versions okay yeah
so I mean we updated a lot of packages
if anybody really wants to know they can
look at the the log of what's changed in
the package.json file but in general it
was Apollo related stuff that we we did
updated there are no breaking changes at
least nothing that I've seen oops I
don't have to do that just in tune and
it does affect an open issue
so let me reference this issue which one
is this I was just reading through it
issue 68
it should pass we're definitely gonna
keep getting a warning until we fix all
the stuff we need to fix from the
materia upgrade awesome we're gonna push
this up to get up with a get push
command and they also you there your so
you can check out that package.json file
on your own now just to see what
versions were running now and and what
all we we just updated and see so hard
just mentioned and the the issue that I
just referenced was an issue that
Harshit had made whenever we first had
to kind of do that work around to get
the beta version to work and the issue
basically just says hey take that
workaround out once we once we do that
you know I can show said amend a file to
a commit
okay so hard [ __ ] let's um if you can if
if you have time to help please let me
know if I'm doing anything wrong but I'm
gonna try to attempt to remove that
extra stuff that we no longer need and
I'm gonna keep an eye on the time let me
see how much some of six minutes okay
you know what let's I only have six
minutes left so I'm not gonna remove
that right now because I think it might
be it'll be more useful to everyone
watching for me to just go through some
of the new stuff because not every I
think it's it's probably gonna be a rare
occurrence that somebody used the same
workaround that we did so but they will
be using some of the newer stuff here so
let's let's do that for now and then
later on I can remove the other stuff so
let's just look at some of the files so
we're gonna go in our pages folder here
are pages so I believe page das has the
new way to do things trying to make some
space here so page Jas yeah here's the
new way so we're using this query we're
using this query component alright and
that's where we're we're getting our
variables and making the query so yeah
so in our get initial props we're
passing in from the route right the ID
and the type which is what we need to
send to WordPress to the graph QL
plug-in and WordPress to get the right
data we're getting this from our server
it pulls it from the URL from the route
once it goes in here and to get initial
props and this is an XJS thing you can't
use this regularly with react then it
it's say
these two props so that way we have
access to this down here for a query
component so we can pass in the type and
the ID and then what we get back is we
do we do some stuff to the data here but
unrelated to the plugin we're working on
right now or graph QL and then we just
post the content this is meant to be a
generic component to where we can route
a lot of stuff into here and it will
display the minimum data but what we
have been doing for certain pieces
certain types of content we want to have
a more specialized template right so
each one of these pages you can consider
it like the the template file for that
that site what's hard saying global X is
still there I said to remove a third
time out sorry I should I guess I just
always forget to remove it I'll remove
it right now there we are the global X
was just there for testing so we don't
really need that there I had totally
forgotten that you said that now that
you bring it up I remember when I asked
you about it but all right so let's go
to one page that I believe we did was it
the faculty page okay I already switched
the faculty page over to the query is it
news there is one page it's still using
the old the old way okay good here's the
one that's using the old way so let's I
have the the font size pretty big but
I'm hoping we can do a kind of a
side-by-side and see so this is what we
we used to do so we we pass the data
like this okay
so we're still passing right the the ID
and we didn't we weren't dealing with
the type because we were sending it
directly to the news query and
everything in the news query was was all
the type called news so let's let's just
switch this over this I guess would be a
good example of just how can you switch
over component quickly so right off the
bat we need some different things right
we don't need page query anymore I'm
sorry we don't need news query anymore I
think we can do this with a regular page
query okay the the difference in queries
and only we need to look at it but
basically this query allows us to pass a
type along with the ID so we're just
going to use this query and it'll really
cut down on the amount of queries that
we need and I'm gonna say page I mean I
suppose I could just copy and paste this
so instead of graph QL we're importing
query and compose and let's see we still
need what's for a component all right
cool that's what we need now let's
scroll down let's scroll down to the
bottom and get rid of this stuff first
so now instead of all of this actually
let's just be easier again to just copy
and paste so basically all this graph QL
stuff can go away and I'm just going to
change this to news okay since this
component is news so now it's a bit more
clean already and we just need to add in
its query component
so I think it would be best to just copy
and paste this query component and we've
already run through what this does and
see we're doing anything different
now we're not huh just double-checking
oh okay I see what we have we do have a
title so let's put this down here for
now and then add in this extra this
extra piece so the difference with our
news component is that we're adding in a
title so let's pull this down and make
sure that we also add in our title and
we're gonna need to wrap this in a div
so this should be fun to wrap everything
in a div I hope and I will say that okay
so title let's see we're gonna find
where there we are there's that last
piece of data we need to get rid of that
was in there from before and we need to
make sure that we are getting back the
title
Wisconsin equals data and let's bring
this back consonant and I believe we are
bringing title in already we'll find out
in a second then we can go check the
query is not working all right cuz it's
not used yet
all right so down here instead of data
news edges right we're gonna use title
okay and the reason we can just do title
right is because well let me see if it
works first and then it'll explain it I
don't want to explain it to you if I
messed it up all right I think that's
all we need to get this to work
whoops I got some expected to be in the
same line that's that's fine
where did that come from
whoops that's my fault I I shouldn't
have put that there they were on
different lines so I didn't realize what
all was going into this is it's not just
data see if I can show you here
so it's the the data is this approach so
it's within data we're looking up this
props type edges node content so what we
need to do instead is add another that's
gonna be and let's put it here so we're
gonna say instead of content title okay
I think it's called title so I think
that'll work we'll find out in a second
there we go
and I did see a question about that node
edges 0 that's the the structure of the
data that we get back from the WP graph
QL plug-in that allows us to use graph
QL with WordPress so that's the
structure so that's that's why we're
working with it in that way and that's
kind of a lot to do so that's it's it
makes sense to just use data and title
down here instead of having a do you
know everything so let's go to new zas
which hasn't been working since we
switched over and let's see if it works
we don't have any links to it so I'm
hoping there's something saved in my
browser there we are No
and this good country property loading
I'm gonna find oh let's see
did we have something
I guess it wasn't a floating okay we can
remove the loading so we have two
loading areas here that we don't need
okay
and do we even need that data no we
don't right we don't need that either
okay so forgot to take that out okay I
should have kept track of how many lines
we were using in that component didn't
remember that I let's try it out
no 1621 that was odd then you refresh
okay there we are I can offer you an
under 500 lucrative minute surrender
collection shows you some I said stay 32
it's possible we might have to make a
change in the server because we were
probably just sending oh you know what
we never changed our get initial props
function there we are now what we can do
actually do we need that this Frost we
don't need this prop site right because
we know it's going to be news
News is not defined because forget to
make it shrink
I think news was let me take the time
okay I'm good on the time I'm gonna look
at the live chat really quickly okay you
are talking about the swipeable drawers
and material you all right yeah I'm
really excited about that
all right let's see with a billing wrong
here
Fisher props a return ID
I probably should check that I actually
have a news item like this with this
slug so I do have the WordPress
installation open on my other screen so
I'm just gonna double check on the slug
here so I don't know if the slug is
right or not I just copy and paste it
just to be sure okay still can't read
property edges on the fine all right
what am i doing
all right so let's see page query so we
are importing page query let me double
check the news query that we had just to
make sure what we were supposed to pass
is correct news yeah okay we are pulling
in the title so that that part should
work news should work let's double check
our while we're here I guess we should
check out our page query so type if we
pass and type it should work here it
should say news all right everything
looks fine for that let's go back to our
I guess we'll double-check the server
and see what we're doing with news see
if we have news in here so we did make
some major changes to the server since
the last time news worked I see some so
a bunch of stuff in the live chat I'm
going to end this in just a minute or
two I just want to try one or two more
things page news just go with
we shouldn't really
yeah we should be alright
okay so faculty page type faculty I mean
we could add in the type here if we
wanted to it's not gonna make a
difference though we're already manually
putting the type in which we may want to
end up doing at some point anyway and
then maybe we could take that news
component a little more reusable for
things other than news
oops
hey a different error like that
I don't think I've seen that one before
oh and what's this
when all else fails just restart your
dev favorite
all right same here
[Music]
mmm
what did I break all right
let me go back I'll make sure I didn't
break everything let's chose in okay so
that's working
all right sue are taken to news
what if let's just take this to page for
a second and see if we can get it to
render like that
really still
so news is being routed to page with the
type of news
what is going on
see what time it is all right I I've got
to be missing something simple I mean at
this point I I totally bypassed the news
component
so are we getting back
let's check our page query news
I don't know what the problem is
oh cool Nikki says I can just type rst
to restart the server no need to control
C and then you are never again alright
cool
that is a good oh it's just RS even
better
okay hard she thinks the workaround is
causing the problem so remove babble
plug-in module alias from package.json
and babble or C alright this will be the
last thing we try and then I'm going to
stop so I can get in some questions
alright it's so where's our PAC babble
se
plug-in module alias can I remove all
the plugins stuff or do we need any any
of this other stuff because it's just
and upgrade next to higher version and
then canary - oh okay so we'll actually
need we need to upgrade a lot of stuff
okay I'm just gonna remove all the
plug-in stuff all right that's gone
where's the package there we go
where's my plugins
all right harsh it was sorry I heard
[ __ ] the bots got you be sincere its
life and a lot of messages okay alright
next Jas up oh okay he did all caps
that's what we mess them up next James
Version is important okay
Babel plug-in module resolver is that
what we don't need anymore I'm just
gonna update neck next 5.0.1 where's
next remove the canary - okay so you
don't need that and then we won't need
this module resolver plugin alright save
that and let's do yarn Oh
looks like I need a version for 5.0.1
interesting should I go down to 5.0 then
or should I just move up to the latest
version
and then canary - okay you're saying
upgrade next - higher version the canary
- okay so we'll do the latest one all
right okay so we've done that let me try
this restart cuz probably need to do
that is nice thanks for that one Nikki
so much faster I'll just have to
remember to do that cuz now it's like in
my muscle memory to just restart it like
manually shut it down and then start it
back up all right cool wha-hoo it worked
and it's not pretty
alright well at least it worked
excellent we did route it through the
page component so let's let's go back
and switch it back just to be sure that
it works with the news component
although you can't get that might be we
might not need the titles we might have
been getting dual titles anyway
alright server and let's route it back
to news
mmm
all right I must have done something
wrong then with that new one if it's
still not working
let's go ahead and just move this let's
just take this entire get initial props
function and move that over here and
then let's change this back from news to
this props type and then that way we
could reuse this we may even end up
renaming it at some point if it helps
all right so we're not getting an error
we're just not getting any data
hmm
interesting I'm not getting any data
really weird
all right one more restart and I'm gonna
start answering questions while I wait
for that if worse comes to worst I can
just run this through the page component
to get it to work and later on figure
out hey why doesn't it work but
hopefully this was you've learned
something I mean there were some cool
tips that came up most of them not from
me so hopefully you learned something
I'm gonna try to go through the comments
now I definitely did more I worked on
this more than I wanted to so I
apologize in advance for if my answers
are kind of short you're shorter than
normal
let's see Odysseus says how long have
you been coding like five years it seems
like I always say five years and I never
change it I guess it's gonna be almost
six years then since I've been streaming
for almost a year so somewhere around
there like five or six years Lamar says
what spec is your MacBook very random
question off topic right now I'm on an
iMac but my my MacBook Pro is I think
it's like the late 2015 MacBook Pro I I
don't remember offhand would it would it
has the the iMac I'm running here I
think is late 2014 and it's like 32 gigs
of RAM I can't remember the processor
sorry about that
if I had more time I'd look it up for
you right now Aniki says how are you
liking fury code with ligatures it's
kind of cool I'm still not like exactly
used to it I still see it I'm like I
looks weird but I I think it'll be good
once I get used to it
and asks what the weather's like today
in my city it's actually not bad it was
about 30 degrees Fahrenheit this morning
I guess in Celsius that's around zero
right where's my my free code camp
Fahrenheit to Celsius converter I don't
even remember where I have that maybe
that's one code then anyway and it's
gonna be about 50 degrees Fahrenheit
later on today so it should be you know
pretty nice I think it's supposed to be
sunny so I'm sure the kids will be
outside playing as soon as they get home
from school
Stephen says Jessie first time being
online watching since I started a new
job Oh awesome
I'm glad you could watch let let me know
how the new jobs going I was wondering
about that to know I hadn't seen you in
a while I know you started so yeah yeah
let me know I'm really interested John
says the tension when you do your short
streams the dev like yet there's so much
pressure when I try to do a short stream
like feel it and things like why can't
things just work when I do a short
stream they'd never work if you believe
it or not when I first started streaming
like on my own channel my goal was to do
a stream than a half hour or less I
don't know how I did it well I mean
nobody watched back then so it was much
easier to you know there'd be like one
person watching so I could keep up with
a live chat a lot easier
Oh Mike Michael how's it going yeah it's
almost over
Harshit I can I can definitely see your
message Michael say Colin John mr. John
like like my daughter did on Friday
Angie says Ola Ola Angie thanks for
joining us and it says what's the first
programming language I learned
JavaScript I did like I messed around
with a couple of different programming
language but the first one that I feel
like I've really learned well enough to
actually build things in other than like
your really basic hello world stuff is
JavaScript I have done a little bit with
Python Java C++ and C all in PHP what I
always forget PHP of course I've you all
see me do PHP stuff
now Phoenix asked if this is over yeah
it's almost over sorry about that it's
shorter than normal
Steven says jobs going great very heavy
on WordPress some programming on the
back end I'm the only developer on a
team with a couple of freelancers
helping so far it's going great awesome
I'm so glad to hear that so just got
back from San Francisco working with a
company website that's pretty massive oh
that's so cool
that's really cool michael says going
back through all the old videos for this
project to figure out what exactly
you're trying to do maybe I ought to go
back through the videos and try to
figure out what we're doing sometimes
[Music]
and this as well it's great you know so
much languages I mean I I don't I don't
know those other languages I just done a
little bit of basic stuff with them so
like I'm I'm somewhat familiar so I
don't I don't wanna I don't wanna make
it seem like I know more than I I really
do
these are says I was a regular watcher
of live session for project three and
then after I discontinued is I still can
connect to this and from this onwards or
should I watch all videos tutorial nice
are I would say like you're probably
fine you just connect with this and keep
watching ask as many questions as you
need to I just think at this point it
would probably really hard to watch all
the videos I mean this is video 50 in
for project five so there's quite a bit
of content so I mean certainly you can
watch it if you want but I don't think
it's necessary and definitely if you're
going to try to watch my old videos put
it on like two times speed or something
it's just so much content Phoenix says I
actually have a degree in IT was
starting free code camp to get at it
again I heard a lot of good things you
have any pointers
I would just say my biggest pointer is
when you're starting out again like just
try to do a little bit every day so it's
much better to do let's say a half hour
every day with free code camp or
whatever you're using to learn then
they're like wait so one day a week like
on the weekend and try to put in eight
hours you'll remember it a lot better so
I mean other than that like I could
probably say a little bit more but I
have officially no time it is 12 o'clock
noon here so I'm gonna have to end the
stream last question how old are you I'm
32 years old
Junaid says you're doing great man thank
you you're welcome
and let's see I thought I I missed some
stuff I did miss some stuff okay I
remember this comment cuz I glanced up
and saw it and it was crazy
in a good way I know bored savage says
Jesse makes major changes in my heart in
a manly way of course and with that
comment I will end thank you so much
everyone sorry that it was a short
stream and that I had never really
figured out exactly what the problem was
sometimes that happens and oh and I just
saw your question I have to go to
another meeting though so just ask me
that question either in the next stream
or like direct message it to me on some
social media thing and I'll be happy to
answer that all right I'll see you all
tomorrow thank you